à la mi journée il y à déjà foule devant
le spectacle du dragon à six têtes sorte
de mise en bouche pour la découverte
d'un univers intérieur oscillant entre
poésie sciences et techniques
un cocktail qui fonctionne puisque la
maison de la magie table cette année sur
une fréquentation record
au delà des 100000 visiteurs un objectif
à portée de billetterie après les
excellents résultats enregistrés pendant
les vacances de la toussaint
c'est l'une des périodes les plus
chargées de l'année on a à la fois la
concordance de tous les habitants de la
région qui reviennent aussi parfois
plusieurs fois dans la semaine
et puis de nombreux touristes alors
cette année particulièrement des
touristes qui viennent de loin des
quatre coins de la france pour moi on
est ravis on m'a bien évidemment la
réussite du lieu tient à la qualité de
ses représentations quotidiennes
l'artiste en scène est l'un des
entraîneurs de l'équipe de france de
magie
il fait partie des plus fervents
supporters de cette maison unique en
europe dédié au père spirituel des
magiciens le célèbre blésois jean eugène
robert houdin
c'est le père de la magie moderne parce
qu'il a transmis de génération en
génération des techniques tout un monde
imaginaire et artistique qui est
toujours d'actualité et même les plus
grands magiciens américains font
référence et appelle à ceux aux
inventions de jean gène robert houdin
[Musique]
encore une fois la magie a opéré et
dehors les prochains visiteurs sont déjà
captivé
pour son 20e anniversaire la maison de
la magie peut voir l'avenir avec
gourmandise
[Musique]